hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery Avengers age of
Ultron review basically like the biggest
Marvel movie you will ever see after
seeing it and listening to some of the
interviews that he's done it's easy to
understand why Joss Whedon kind of wants
to like transition from doing Marvel
films to doing really small indie films
and just consulting on all the phase
three films seriously the first cut of
the film was three and a half hours long
the end running time is closer to like
two and a half hours so it's still
really long protip I would recommend you
get the small drink lest you have to
leave the theater like three or four
times to go to the bathroom I know I
shouldn't be surprised to but I got home
for my screening and I was already being
tweeted links from like pirated you know
WTF scenes in the movie I was a little
surprised at how fast it happened I mean
everything leaks eventually but I know
it wasn't someone inside the movie
theater that I was at the print that I
saw was like the 11th film in an 11 film
marathon and after every movie they
would cyclists in and out of the theater
before Avengers age of Ultron they took
all of our phones and wanted us down
like we were getting ready to go on an
airplane if you're not familiar with it
the El Capitan the the place where they
did this big Marvel Marathon is the same
theater a couple months ago where they
did their big phase 3 announcement were
they now - you know Captain America
Civil War all the other films that are
gonna be happening for the next 5 years
they joked it in another five years
they'll turn it into like a 36 hour
movie marathon so you have your chance
in another five years to do this again
just to talk about the characters a
little bit you know Joss Whedon said
going into this this is gonna be you
know much more of a Hulk Hawkeye film
versus the other Avengers like you know
typically Tony Stark Captain America you
know they're the biggest characters but
in this film he chooses to focus on some
of the lesser characters it's really fun
when you go back and you watch say like
Mark Ruffalo's Hulk performance and
Avengers 1 and then you watch it now and
just to see how he's evolved the film
itself isn't constructed so much on the
big action set-pieces in the way that
the first Avengers film is constructed
Joss Whedon said that like when he went
to write this he built it based on the
moments between characters that he
wanted to see so this is like the
biggest Marvel character film that
you've ever seen that's why I think
it'll be easier for this film to stand
the test of time then like the other big
Marvel films there are a couple things
weighing it down like I said you know
it's a two-and-a-half-hour movie so
there's like a lot of stuff in there
maybe not like every single character
you've ever seen in the history
the Marvel Universe but just about if
you are a big Joss Whedon fan like a fan
of the way he writes jokes and kind of
his Shakespearean style this is gonna be
your big film he said going into the
first Avengers film he joined the team
like the production team a little late
in the game so he really he didn't have
as much time to make it his own film as
he did with this film literally the idea
for this film came when he went to have
his first meeting with Marvel about
Avengers 1
he explained that that was all about
Ultron he's like I want Ultron to be the
villain and I want Paul Bettany to
become the vision that was the Marvel
film that he wanted to make whenever he
was meeting for Avengers 1 so he was
like ok I'll do this Avengers film but
then I want to do this other big
Avengers film and Kevin fight he was
like ok that's great let's do that and
the fun thing about this big Marvel
marathon is that Kevin Feige he actually
came for several of the films to intro
them like they they would roll out like
you know writers like James Gunn came to
intro guardians of the galaxy when they
got to that Jaime Alexander came to
introduce tour of the dark world so they
had they had like big directors come out
and before they screened age of Ultron
they actually they showed a 3d print of
the ant-man trailer I think a man is
gonna be a lot of fun in 3d but we could
talk about that later even though the
film Center is very much on on Hulk and
Hawkeye really the breakaway stars like
the ones you'll walk away thinking about
the most I think are Paul Bettany's
performance as the vision and James
Spader's performance as Ultron just to
start with Ultron he is probably the
funniest scariest robot you will ever
see in a movie if you've ever watched
blacklist it's a very dark drama show
his character Raymond Reddington gets a
lot of jokes in think of it as humor in
that sense only you know if it were
written by Joss Whedon so it's like Joss
Whedon jokes flowing from the darkest
scariest mouth you could possibly
imagine in another week when we get to
my spoiler review I can explain a little
bit better why he's such a funny
character just because there's some
specific plot points tied to it Paul
Bettany is the vision though I'm really
interested to see which female fans walk
away from this film fangirling on him
versus like you know Bucky in Captain
America Winter Soldier or Chris Evans or
Thor or like you know the people that
you would normally expect people to
fangirl on some of the most difficult
moments in the film are vision moments
seriously once this movie hits DVD
tumblr is gonna explode it's gonna be so
much fun the reason I think
Paul Bettany worked so well as the
vision is because joss whedon you know
comes from this shakespeare place where
a lot of his creative energy comes from
and paul bettany is amazing at that so
so Joss Whedon's words coming out of
Paul Bettany's mouth just sounds so much
better than any other choices they could
have made for the vision character a big
part of that casting choice is also tied
up in the the plot of the movie Jarvis
himself is actually a really interesting
character in this film he's if he's very
distinct from the vision character even
though Paul Bettany does voices for both
but just to be clear Jarvis's is like
more of an ethereal cloud like that
there's no face attached to him vision
on the other hand is like literally paul
bettany walking around on screen it's
not motion capture that's why I just I
cannot wait to see how they're gonna
integrate vision into the future phase 3
films they haven't made any
announcements yet so I don't have any
rumors to give you guys right now the
biggest complaint I'm seeing from
traditional critics is that there's like
so much of the film dedicated to setting
up the phase 3 films but that's that's
expected like they told us they were
gonna do that and I feel like if you go
into a Marvel film you expect them to
set up other films in some ways you know
using post-credit scenes using plot
points so there is a lot of that in
there but it is important and you'll
understand why when you see the film
they do a good job of setting up the
other phase 3 films without like going
on a wide tangent like they don't derail
the film just to set up you know Thor 3
Captain America Civil War I feel like
even though they crammed everything in
the kitchen sink into the movie it works
much better thematically than the first
Avengers film like you could argue that
the first Avengers film is just a bunch
of big action set pieces sewn together
this film flows much more like a
traditional film like it's not just them
flying from big fight to big fight to
big fight I think one of my few
disappointments with the film is that we
didn't spend quite as much time as I
wanted to with the Black Widow character
but I totally understand why they can't
do that like you know it's a big film
they've already got so much in there
they can only spend so much time with
the characters and in Joss Whedon really
chose to go with Hulk and Hawkeye then
you have to work in four new characters
including Ultron vision Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch like you have to give them
their moments - and a lot of people feel
weird about quicksilver's accent it's
not that big a thing like it won't
completely take you out of the film
really the breakaway Maximoff twin is
Elizabeth also
but but she's a great actress I'm
actually a big fan of hers if you
haven't seen any of her indie stuff
check out some of her indie films she's
like one of those actors like Mark
Ruffalo that you know that will do like
a big film like this but most of the
time they spend their time doing like
really small character films that are
that I think are much more rewarding for
the actors yes you know you get like the
giant paycheck for the big Avengers film
but if you really want like a
challenging character film like you
really have to make like a small indie
film yourself that's why I'm really
hoping at some point to see some
collaboration with Robert Downey jr.
team Downey films that's like his
production company that he uses to make
films in Mark Ruffalo like Mark Ruffalo
makes a film funded by a team Downey
that would be amazing
Robert Downey jr. ZAR really interesting
presence in the film you get a sense
that in real life he senses like okay
I'm getting a little long in the tooth
so I can't you know hold these films up
all by myself we need to start relying
on the ensemble so they weave him into
the film and kind of explain where his
characters going in the future in a way
that will allow him to take a diminished
role like thematically going into
Captain America Civil War next year
you'll understand why even though he's
in the film it's still a Captain America
Chris Evans film a lot of people are
choosing to call that Avengers 2.5 any
kind of is because there are gonna be
like a ton of characters in there but it
will still be a Captain America film
walking away from the film though the
character that I am most excited to see
more from in the future in like you know
the Phase three films is Paul Bettany as
the vision if you're a big comic book
fan then you ply read some vision
stories before you understand like why
it's such an interesting character to
explore in the future but even if you're
just seeing him for the first time in
age of Ultron you'll totally understand
like after you see his scenes you'll
totally understand why he is like the
most interesting character in the
history of the Marvel Universe I will go
as far to say that vision is so much fun
that I will totally not be pissed if
they cut Adam warlock out of guardians
of the galaxy to like if they don't do
Adam warlock at all in the Marvel
Universe I will totally be happy if
vision becomes his placeholder I
realized that gets into like Thanos
Infinity Gauntlet storyline stuff I'll
save a lot of that for my spoiler review
just because the film does address that
in a really interesting way so be sure
to subscribe to get that what I'm gonna
do is I'll probably wait until the film
is going to be released in the United
States because I think that's the last
place that it's dropping that should be
made first so it's gonna be about a week
or so before I post that
feel free to ask any like specific plot
point questions you have and if you've
seen the film and you want to comment on
spoilers just please use a spoiler tag
just like you do on my Game of Thrones
videos so what's happening next is I'm
gonna post my arrow video next because
that's tonight then I'll get through
agents of shield and then I'll try and
get through the rest of my daredevil
videos before the weekend daredevil has
been picked up for season two but the
show runners are gonna be different so
whenever I post my next daredevil video
I'll explain that or at least by my
agents of shield video just in case you
guys haven't seen it you can click here
for last night's episode of the flash I
just I post that like super early this
morning and you can click here for all
my other Avengers Marvel videos thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you